the cdc continues to update its covet 19
safety guidelines they keep updating
them
and they have confirmed that kovid
spreads through the air
not through surface contact in other
words disinfecting surfaces
doesn't really help stop covid so we can
stop
wiping everything down now so we can
touch stuff now that's great
yeah yeah now the science is always a
little complicated so the cdc released
a public service announcement to explain
things
in a simple direct way take a look
hi i'm tammy lassname with the center
for disease control
recently we updated our guidelines on
how to help best stop the spread of
covet 19.
because kovid is an airborne disease
disinfectants are not necessarily
helpful
therefore surfaces are safe to touch
which means guess what you're allowed to
lick again you little freaks
you can french kiss everything now
i miss this baby this is a tongue yeah
that tongue was ready to go
wasn't it click click click click click
oh tastes like music let your tongues
roll the countryside
yeah put your tongue on it i said put
your tongue on it
this message has been approved by the
cdc
i'm not sure that was a great psa it's
not going to stop me
you like you're a liquor aren't you sure
am have you licked every single
cardboard cutout in this
audience oh yeah
well thank god i had them laminated a
long time ago
and sprayed with a minty flavor